ونبقى مشاهدينا مع اخبار كره القدم حيث
جرت منذ قليل في مدينه نيو السويسريه
مراسم قرعه ثمن نهائي دوري ابطال اوروبا
لكره القدم اذا
20223 للحديث عن الموضوع معي في الاسود
التي اسفرت عنها القرعه وكيف نفسر بروز
يعني مواجهات همم قويه في الادوار الاولى
ايضا بين ليفربول وريال مدريد في اعاده
لنهائي العام الماضي ذلك كان القرعه على
اساس نتائج دور المجموعات اي في الدور
الاول الانديه التي تنهي في المرتبه
الاولى تواجه انديه انها في المرتبه
الثانيه وباريس سان جيرمان مثلا في
مجموعته انها ثانيا خلف بنفيكا فكان من
المتوقع ان يواجه فريق قوي وهذا ما حصل مع
المواجهه ضد فريق بايرن ميونخ الفريق
الالماني تذكرون هذه المواجهه بنهائي عام
2020 عام كوفيد حينما كانت اقيمت البطوله
في ليشبونه ابتداء من ادور ربع النهائي
اذا المواجهه الان بين باريس سان جيرمان
بطل فرنسا وبايرن ميونخ بطل
بطوله المحليه مواجهه جديده ايضا بين
الفريقين همم اكثر من مره بعد انتهاء عام
2020 في همم ربع النهائي همم بطوله 2021
اي قبل موسم وحينها باريس سان جيرمان تمكن
من ان همم
بهدف همم ايضا او فزع عليه واحد توفر
اثنين ثلاثه واتاهل الى نصف نهائي حينها
اذا باريس سان جيرمان الذي كان ينتظر
الخصم في موسم مهم جدا بالنسبه للفريق
البريسي همم هو الذي همم يريد ان يفوز
باللقب للمره الاولى همم في تاريخ يبحث عن
ذلك منذ سنوات وسنوات
ويعتبر ان هذا الموسم ربما باريس سان
جيرما حظوظه اقوى من المعتاد ماذا بانه
يعتمد على هذا الثلاثي الهجومي
ونيمار وليونيل ميسي ربما افضل هجوم في
الانديه الاوروبيه همم هذه الايام هذا
بالنسبه للقاء باريس سان جيرمان بايرن
ميونخ همم بين متصدر ايضا الدوري الفرنسي
حاليا ومتصدر الدوري الالماني اللقاء
الاخر الكبير يجمعوا همم ليفربول بيريال
مدريد ذهب على ملعب انفيلد رود في انجلترا
في اعاده لنهائي الموسم الماضي هي
المباراه النهائيه التي جرت هنا في باريس
واسفل عن الكثير من المشاكل بين الناحيه
الامنيه ليفربول ريال مدريد ريال همم
دائما في افضل حالته في ما مستوى ليفربول
تراجعه كثيرا هذا الموسم ولكن الامور ربما
تكون مختلفه عن اساس ان المباريات سنعود
الى ذلك تقاموا العام المقبل بعد
المونديال من بين اللقاءات المهمه نرى ان
همم مثلا مانشستر سيتي الفريق الانجليزي
الذي لم يصدق له ان توج باللقب طامح للفوز
الاول
ويواجهه فريق ربما اقل شان من فريق اللاعب
زيك همم من المانيا مانشستر سيتي الذي
يعتمد على هداف فيه افضل هداف حاليا في
اوروبا النرويجي على لقاء ايضا بين ميلان
وتوتنهام مع مواجهه بين حديثي منتخب فرنسا
الحالي لوريس حديث توتنهام والمقبل من يوم
حارس ميلان هذه هي ابرز المواجهات نرانا
هناك ايضا لقاء بين الانتر وبورتو بين
بروسيا دورتموند وتشيلسي كلوبج وبنفيكا
ونابولي نرى ايضا انديه جديده تشارك للمره
الاولى في هذا المستوى بطل بلجيكا كلوب او
فريق ايتراك فرانكفورت حامل لقب الي
اوروبا المسابقه الاوروبيه الثانويه في
الموسم الماضي اخيرا بنسبه لتاريخ مباريات
الذهاب تقاموا في همم في شهر شباط فبراير
ذهابا اذا في الرابع عشر الخامس عشر الحدي
والعشرين والثاني والعشرين وايابا في شهر
التالي اذار مارس في السابع الثامن الرابع
عشر والخمسه عشر على اساس مبارتين في
اليوم الواحد المباريات توزع على اربعه
ايام وعلى اسبوعين هي مباريات همم ده
مرسوم من النهائي من دوري ابطال اوروبا
لكره القدم
اشكرك
على كل هذه